creo que no es ningún secreto que si
hacemos cualquier tipo de ciencia vamos
a lidiar con muchos números no
importando si hacemos biología química o
física los números están involucrados y
en muchos casos los números son muy
largos son
me
muy
números muy largos o son números muy
pequeños son
prost
qué
niños
puedes imaginar números muy largos si te
pregunto cuántos átomos ha en el cuerpo
humano o cuántas células hay en el
cuerpo humano o la masa de la tierra en
kilogramos esos son números muy grandes
si te preguntará la masa de un electrón
ese sería un número muy muy pequeño por
lo que cada tipo de ciencia va a estar
lidiando con esto y sólo como un ejemplo
déjame enseñarte uno de los números más
comunes que vas a ver especialmente en
química este se llama el número de
avogadro
ga
pero
y si fuera a escribirlo en la manera
estándar de escribir un número sería
literalmente escrito como sería 60 22 y
otros 20 0 2 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 y
aunque le dibuje unas comas no va a
mejorar la situación para que sea más
legible deja dibujó unas comas aquí
es aún un gran número y ni siquiera sé
si tuviera que dibujar esto en un trozo
de papel si tuviera que publicar un
escrito usando el número de avogadro me
tomaría para siempre escribir esto y
sería aún más difícil darme cuenta si se
me olvidó anotar un cero o si quizá
escribir demasiados ceros
así que hay un problema aquí hay alguna
mejor manera de escribir esto hay una
describir esto que escribirlo todo de
esta manera de escribir literalmente el
6 seguido de los 23 dígitos o describir
el 6 022 seguido de los 2002 de ahí y
para contestar esta pregunta y en caso
de que seas curioso el número de abogado
si tienes 12 gramos de carbono si tienes
12 gramos de carbono 12 esto es la
cantidad de átomos que vas a tener y
solo para que lo sepas donde queramos es
como un treinta bode una libra así que
eso solo te da una idea de cuántos
átomos están por ahí en cualquier
instante
esto es un número muy grande el punto
aquí es enseñarte un poco de química y
el punto aquí es hablar de una manera
más sencilla de escribir esto y la
manera más fácil de escribir esto la
llamamos notación científica no
notación 100
si acá
y toma mi palabra que esto puede ser un
poco inusual para ti pero realmente es
una manera más fácil de escribir cosas
como esa así que antes de que te muestre
cómo hacer esto déjame mostrarte la
teoría fundamental detrás de la notación
científica
si fuera a decirte cuánto es 10
a la potencia cero
sabemos que es igual a 1
cuánto es 10
a la potencia 1 entonces es igual a
al cuadrado eso es
por 10
lo que es igual
a 100
cuánto es 10
al cubo
tiene el cubo es
por 10
lo que es igual
a mil
y creo que ves un patrón general aquí 10
a 0 no tiene ceros
ellos
10 a la 1 tiene
luego
pieza al cuadrado tiene 2
el boss
y finalmente 10 al cubo tiene 3 ceros y
puedo seguir haciendo lo mismo pero creo
que ya tienen la idea son
lobos
si hiciera si hiciera pies a la potencia
la potencia 100
cómo se vería eso y no me siento con
ganas de escribir todo esto aquí pero
sería un 1 seguido de y ustedes pueden
adivinar lo 100 ceros
así que serían un montón de ceros si
contáramos todos los ceros tendrías
cruz ahí y de hecho esto podría ser
interesante puedes o no saber cómo se
llama este número se llama se llama
google google en el principio de los 90
si alguien decía hey ese es un google no
hubieras pensado en un motor de búsqueda
hubieras pensado en el número 10 a la
potencia 100 el cual es un gran número
es mayor que la cantidad de átomos más
bien que la cantidad estimada de átomos
en el universo conocido en el universo
conocido me refiero a y digo está la
pregunta de que otra cosa hay allá
afuera pero leí sobre esto hace poco
tiempo y si no me equivoco el universo
conocido está en el orden de diez
a la 81 átomos y esto por supuesto es
difícil nadie puede realmente contar
esto la gente solo intenta estimar lo o
aún mejor adivinarlo pero este es un
gran número y quizás sea más interesante
para ti que este número fue la
motivación detrás de un motor de
búsqueda muy poderoso si de google
gu
google es esencialmente un error
ortográfico de la palabra google y no sé
por qué le llaman google tal vez
obtuvieron el nombre del dominio tal vez
querían almacenar esa gran cantidad de
información tal vez esos mili bytes de
información o es una palabra en onda
cualquiera que sea la razón quizá tal
vez era el número favorito del fundador
pero es interesante saberlo pero venga
volvamos al tema
este es un google es un 1 con 100 ceros
y equivalentemente hemos escrito eso
como 10 al asiento y esto es claramente
esto es una manera más sencilla de
escribir esto esto es
sí
de hecho esto es tan difícil de escribir
que ni me tome la molestia de escribirlo
me hubiera tomado toda la vida en este
sólo eran 2002 con 100 ceros hubiera
llenado la pantalla y tuvieras aburrido
por lo que ni siquiera lo escribí
claramente escribir esto es más fácil
y entonces puedes ver que esto es bueno
para potencias de 10 verdad pero como
podemos escribir algo que no es
directamente una potencia base de 10
cómo podemos utilizar el poder de la
sencillez cómo podemos utilizar el poder
de la sencillez de alguna manera y para
hacer eso solo necesitas hacer lo
siguiente este número este número lo
podemos escribir como
entonces cuántos dígitos tiene en él
tiene 1 2 3 y 2002 así que tiene 23
dígitos después del 6 verdad 23 dígitos
después del 6
y qué pasa si tengo si quiero acercarme
a él utilizando una potencia de 10
qué pasa si dijera 10 a la 23
a la potencia 23
eso aquí es igual eso es igual a 1 con
23 02 esto es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 tienes
la idea eso es 10 a la 23
ahora podemos de alguna manera escribir
a este amigo como múltiplo de este amigo
pues podemos porque si multiplicamos
este amigo por 6 así que cuanto es 6 si
multiplicamos 6 por 10
a la 23
que tenemos tenemos un 6 con 23 ceros
vamos a tener un 6
y luego tendrá 23 ceros
déjame escribir eso tendrás 23 02 aquí
así que si tienes 6 por esto y sabes
cómo multiplicar esto tiene 6 por este
16 y todos los demás 6 por 0 van a ser
cero así que 6 seguido de 23 ceros
esto es bastante útil aunque aún no
llegamos a este número es decir este
tiene unos 2 por ahí por lo que como
podemos hacerlo mejor o qué tal si lo
escribimos como un decimal este número
este número de aquí es idéntico a este
número si estos dos fueran cero pero
queremos poner esos dos es entonces que
haremos podemos poner unos decimales
aquí y podemos decir que esto es lo
mismo que 6.022 x
a la 23
y ahora este número es idéntico a este
número pero es una manera mucho más
fácil de escribirlo y puedes verificar
lo si quieres te tomará algo de tiempo
quizá pero debemos de hacerlo con un
número más pequeño primero pero si
multiplicas 6.0 22 por 10 a la 23 y lo
escribes todo obtendrás este número de
aquí obtendrás el número de avogadro
pero
número d
por acá
pero
y aunque este se vea un poco complicado
o sea poco intuitivo para ti al inicio
ya sabes este es sólo un número escrito
y éste tiene una multiplicación y luego
un 10 elevado a una potencia y dirás y
eso no es tan simple pero realmente sí
lo es porque inmediatamente sabes
cuántos ceros hay y obviamente es una
manera mucho más corta de escribir este
número hagamos unos más
empecé con el número de abogado porque
realmente te muestra la necesidad de una
notación científica para que no tengas
que escribir cosas como esa una y otra
vez así que hagamos un par más de
números y escribamos los en notación
científica entonces digamos que tengo el
número digamos que tengo el número 7.345
y lo quiero escribir en notación
científica por lo que creo la mejor
manera de pensar en eso es
es 7.345 así que cómo puedo representar
algo como miles lo escribiré aquí y es
al cubo es 1000 entonces sabemos que 10
al cubo es igual a mil esa es de hecho
la potencia más grande de 10 que puede
caber en esto esto es 7 mil entonces
este es 7000 luego es punto 3 de 1000
luego es punto 04 de 1000 y no sé si
esto te ayuda podemos escribir esto como
7 punto
45 por 10 a la 3
porque van a ser siete miles más punto
tres mil es cuánto es punto tres por mil
puntos tres por mil trescientos cuánto
es punto 0 4 por mil es 40 cuánto es
punto 0 0 5 por mil es un 5 por lo que
7.345 por 1000 es igual a 7 mil 345
déjalo multiplicó para hacerlo más claro
si tomo 7.345
la manera en la que lo hago es ignoro
los ceros y esencialmente multiplico uno
por este amigo de ahí arriba y obtengo 7
345 luego tengo 3 ceros aquí por lo que
los pongo
al final
y luego tengo tres decimales uno dos
tres
entonces es 1 2 3 ponemos el decimal ahí
y ahí lo tienen 7.345 por 1000 es de
hecho 7 mil 345 hagamos uno más
digamos que queremos escribir el número
6 en notación científica así que no hay
necesidad de escribirlo en notación
científica pero como lo harías cuál es
la mayor potencia de 10 que cabe en 6
bueno la potencia mayor que cabe en 6 es
sólo 1 así que podemos escribirlo como
algo por 10
a la 0 esto es solo
una verdad esto es solo uno así que seis
es que por uno
entonces 6 es igual a 6 por 10 al a 0 y
no tendrías que escribirlo de esta
manera de hecho esta es más fácil pero
te muestra que es posible expresar
cualquier número en notación científica
ahora
qué pasa si ahora queremos representar
algo así recuerdo que al inicio del
vídeo mencioné que en la ciencia lidias
con números muy grandes y muy pequeños
digamos que tienes el número punto 1 2 3
45 ceros seguidos de un 7
y una vez más no es fácil trabajar con
este número pero cómo podemos lidiar con
él con una potencia de 10 como una
potencia de 10 así que cuál es la mayor
potencia de 10 que cabe en este número
por la que este número es divisible
pensemos en eso todas las potencias de
10 que hicimos antes iban a positivo y
van bueno eran potencias positivas de 10
podemos también hacer potencias
negativas de 10 sabes que 10
al acero
empecemos a y 10 al menos 1 es igual
a 1 sobre 10
lo que es igual a
punto 1
pies al menos 2 es igual
1 sobre 10
al cuadrado que es igual a 1 sobre
que es igual
punto cero
y creo que ya tienes la idea o déjame
hacer uno más para que tengas la idea 10
al menos 3
10 a la menos 3 es igual a 1 sobre 10
al cubo que es igual a 1 sobre 1000
que es igual
a punto
el patrón general aquí es 10 a cualquier
potencia negativa es los lugares que
tendrás que recorrer después del punto
decimal aquí no es el número de ceros
tienes 10 a la menos 3 sólo tienes dos
ceros pero tienes 3 lugares después del
punto decimal así que cuál es la mayor
potencia de 10 que cabe en esto o
cuántos decimales tengo después del
punto decimal tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6
por lo que 10 a la menos seis
va a ser igual
punto y vamos a tener seis lugares
después del punto decimal y el último
lugar va a ser un 1 así que tenemos
cinco ceros
y un 1 eso es 10 a la menos 6 ahora este
número de aquí el 7 por este número si
multiplicamos esto por 7 por 7 tenemos 7
por 1 y luego tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6
números después del punto decimal así
que es
por lo que este número por 7 es
claramente el número con el que
empezamos
así que podemos reescribir este número
en vez de en vez de escribir este número
siempre podemos escribirlo como siento
igual a este número o podemos escribir 7
esto es igual a
7 por este número este número no es
mejor que este número pero este número
es igual a 10 a la menos 67 x
10 al menos 6 por lo que ahora puedes
imaginar números como
imagina el número que si tenemos un 7
déjame pensarlo de esta manera que si
tengo un 7 si tenemos un 7 3 ahí
entonces que hacemos primero queremos ir
al primer dígito de aquí porque este es
como la mayor potencia de 10 que puede
caber aquí así que si queremos
representar esa cosa
déjame escribir déjame hacer otro
decimal que sea como ese digamos que
tengo punto 0 0005 16 y quiero
representar esto en notación científica
voy al primer dígito diferente de 0 que
está ahí y ahora cuál es la potencia
mayor de 10 que cabrá ahí así que
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 así que va a ser igual
a 5.1
entonces tomó el 5 y todo lo demás
estará después del punto decimal
x
qué es
y esto será la mayor potencia de 10 que
quepa en este primer número diferente de
cero tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 entonces es 10 a
la potencia menos 5
déjame hacer otro ejemplo el punto al
que quiero llegar es que vas al primer
pasa al primero empezando desde la
izquierda el primer dígito distinto a 0
y de ahí es de donde obtiene su potencia
de ahí es de donde obtuve mi 10 a la
menos 5 porque tuve 1 2 3 4 5 tienes que
contar ese número igual que como lo
hicimos aquí y luego todo lo demás
estará después del decimal déjame hacer
otro ejemplo
tiene un punto y mi hermano siempre me
dice que tengo que escribir un cero
antes de mi punto decimal porque él es
doctor y si la gente no ve el punto
decimal alguien puede pasarse de la
dosis en algún medicamento así que
escribamos lo a su manera
0 punto
00 08 192
claramente este es un número super
difícil de escribir y podrías olvidar un
cero con tantos ceros lo que puede traer
alteraciones importantes si estás
haciendo investigación científica
importante o tal vez tú o tal vez pre
escribas medicina mal pero como
escribirías esto en notación científica
entonces empiezo con el primer dígito
diferente de 0 empezando desde la
izquierda va a ser 8.192 solo puse un
punto decimal y escribí punto 192 x por
a la que solo debes de contar 10 a la 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
tengo que incluir ese número 10 a la
menos diez y creo lo encontrará
razonablemente satisfactorio que este
número es más fácil de escribir que ese
número ahora y esta es otra cosa
poderosa de la anotación científica
digamos que tengo estos dos números y
quiero multiplicar los digamos que
quiero multiplicar el número punto
5 x
por el número por el número punto
008 de hecho ésta es bastante directa
pero algunas veces puede volverse muy
complicado y especialmente si estás
lidiando con 20 o 30 ceros en cualquiera
de los dos lados del punto decimal
déjame pongo unos ceros aquí para hacer
a mi hermano feliz y
hacerlo en notación científica lo
simplificar a bastante
este amigo puede ser reescrito como 5
por 10 a la que tengo 123 espacios
después del punto que es 10 a la menos
y luego esto es 8 entonces esto es por 8
por 10
a la entonces a cuánto es igual este
amigo tenemos 1 2 3 4 lugares después
del punto decimal así que es 8 por 10 a
la menos 4 entonces para multiplicar
números si estamos multiplicando estas
dos cosas esto es lo mismo que 5
por 10
- 3
por 8 por 10
a la menos 4
no hay nada especial en la notación
científica literalmente significa lo que
dice por lo que para multiplicar los
puedes escribirlos así y el orden de la
multiplicación no importa así que puedo
reescribir los como 5
por 8
por 10
al menos 3
a la menos
y luego cuánto es 5 por 8 5 por 8
sabemos que es 40
así que es 40 por 10 al menos 3 por
al menos 4
y si saben las reglas de los exponentes
sabes que cuando multiplicas dos números
que tienen la misma base
puedes sólo sumar sus exponentes así que
sólo sumar al menos tres y el menos
cuatro así que será 40
al menos 100
hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que vamos a
multiplicar el número de abogados así
que sabemos que 6 puntos
22 por 10 a la 23
digamos que vamos a multiplicar eso por
un número muy pequeño entonces es por
digamos 7
punto
23 por 10
al menos 22 así que este número es muy
pequeño vas a tener un punto decimal y
luego 21 ceros
luego vas a tener un 7 un 2 y un 3 por
lo que este es un número muy pequeño
pero la multiplicación cuando la haces
en notación científica es de hecho
bastante directa
esto va a ser 6.022 por 10
a la 23
x
7 punto
por 10 al menos 20 2 podemos cambiar el
orden entonces es 6.022 por 7.23 esta
parte puedes verla como la primera parte
de la anotación científica por por 10
23 por 10
al menos 20 2
y ahora aquí vas a tener que hacer una
pequeña multiplicación con decimales
esto sería 40 y algo creo hoy no puedo
hacerlo mentalmente pero esta parte es
muy fácil de calcular esta de aquí la
dejaré así pero esta sería por 10 a la
23 por 10 a la menos 22 tú solo suman
los exponentes y queda por 10 a la
potencia 1
y este número a lo que sea que sea igual
solo lo dejaré aquí porque no tengo una
calculadora
por 7.2 3
veamos cómo sería sería 7.2 veamos punto
2 es como un quinto será como 41 punto
algo por lo que esto es aproximadamente
41 por 10
a la 1
y otra manera es aproximadamente 410
algo
y para obtener lo mejor tienes que de
hecho desarrollar esta multiplicación
así que ojalá hayas visto que la
notación científica es muy útil para
números muy grandes o muy pequeños y no
solo es más fácil entender los números y
escribir los números sino también
simplifica a operar los números